one thing I've heard from a lot of
people is and I think when we pulled our
podcast Community about this one thing
that really came up was people feeling
lost yeah
yeah and maybe I should have said that
earlier but that's essentially I think
all those feelings wrapped up in one
title and one word would be the we're
being lost would be the feeling of being
lost right and I think that all comes
down to this expectation that you need
to be on the right path right now you
need to have everything figured out
right now and that is not the case and I
think in our 20s we are bombarded by all
of these Life Choices that we need to
make we were talking about some before
right
should I move to a new country should I
go and do my doctorate degree should I
just quit my job and go traveling and
all of those things paralyze us because
we're overcome by this thing called the
Paradox of choice and I also think this
is something that's come up a lot more
in in the last like 20 30 years
we're presented with so many options
which is a good thing that it paralyzes
us and we can't even make one and there
was this really interesting experiment
they did on this a little bit of a
tangent but
these psychologists from Stanford they
went to the farmer's market and they set
up a stall for jam and on day one they
had 27 jams for sale and on day two they
only had five and we think and they
wanted to see how many how many times
people purchased the jam and on the
second day when people only had five
options their sales were like up 300 and
it shows us that we actually don't want
as many choices as we think that we do
and when we do have more choices we're
less likely to act on those and we feel
lost because we're unsure of whether
we're going to make the right decision
so that's another kind of psychological
element behind this experience
I guess part of this this feeling of
feeling lost or directionless is this
idea of
needing to have sorted out
like your ideal life yeah like I've
heard a lot of people say that like oh I
don't know what to do with my life
and and the implication there is that
that is a really bad thing yeah um and
sometimes even like when I talk to my
mum she will say that she'll look at my
career and say that like I don't have
any direction in my career or something
like that that's so funny and I'd kind
of be like that is true but it's also
not necessarily a bad thing but at the
same time the phrase you have no
Direction your career is definitely a
negative rather than oh you don't have
any directing career well done you yeah
yeah how do you how yeah what's what do
you what are your thoughts on that I
really I really like this this train of
thought here because I I think about
this a lot
I think that a lack of direction is
comes up very negative but it also means
an abundance of opportunity and that's
something that we need to realize and
one of my good friends said this to me
the other day because I recently started
doing my own show full time it was a
massive risk for me I took a massive
like step away from the financial
security that my nine to five offered me
I did something a little bit against the
grain and the thing that really like
struck me was because this path is
unconventional I have no idea like
podcasting hasn't really existed for
that long right I have no idea where I'm
gonna be in like five years time or 10
years or when I'm 50. and if I continue
to work in my nine to five I would know
I would know that you know you move up
between you move up the ranks you'll pay
increases you have a family all those
things right and what she said to me and
it really stuck with me was stop trying
to imagine what your life looks like
down to the detail and just imagine how
you want your life to feel like on an
average Monday afternoon
and I was like wow that is so profound
she was like picture yourself at 50 and
what are you doing on a Monday night
and what does that entail because you're
not going to be thinking about all the
all the Milestones that you hit you're
successful things you've done you're not
going to be putting the pressure on
yourself to meet all these certain you
know goals instead when you think about
it that way you just think about what
kind of Life do I want to be living what
emotions do I want to be feeling and you
acknowledge that there will be multiple
paths to get there and I think that
that's very liberating right so I said
to her like I would want to be living in
a big city and I'd want to be having
people over for dinner that I'd met you
know in various places maybe I'd have a
few people living with me who had picked
up along the way friends family random
acquaintances and I want to be able to
come back and talk to my friends or talk
to my partner about an amazing day that
I had and I want to feel loved and I
want to feel happy and it doesn't matter
what happened before that as long as I'm
in that spot and I think that is a much
better frame of mind to be in rather
than to look at your life as a series of
Milestones that you need to hit or a
series of decisions that you need to
make and a correct way of going about
your 20s and then also your broader life
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye